ferme des crooces épines est un petit
paradis pour les animaux et
principalement pour les quelques 200
chèvres qui sont élevé afin qu'aucune de
ces bête ne finissent à l'abattoir
Alexandra d pont y a même créé un refuge
cette productrice de fromage bio n'avait
pu prendre de vacances depuis de longues
années et puis elle a rencontré Aurélien
un instituteur Picard il est venu une
première fois en woofing en tant que
bénévole à la toussin 2013 et d'emblé ça
a été un bénévole assez exceptionnel d'
il m'a dit moi ce que ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de voir si je suis capable de de
gérer la ferme il s'était vraiment posé
un challenge donc tout de suite pendant
les 10 jours il avait été curieux tout
très rigoureux au petit soin avec les
chèvres et vraiment une personne qui
avait vraiment envie de d'être autonome
très vite surtout séduit par la méthode
d'élevage et la philosophie d'Alexandra
l'institte est revenu à plusieurs
reprises sur ses congés et puis il a
fini par proposer à l'éleveuse de
prendre quelques jours de vacances avec
sa petite fille ça a pas été facile de
la convaincre parce que c'est difficile
pour elle aussi de laisser tout le chtel
c'est son outil de travail malgré tout
ça s'est plutôt bien passé on a eu
quelques petits pépins où par téléphone
alexandra a vraiment pu nous dépanner
nous conseiller mais pour résumer on va
dire que de longues journées bien
remplies
et avec des moments très très très
sympathiques d'échang avec mes sœurs les
amis et surtout avec des biquettes en
septembre Aurélien retrouvera ses petits
élèves picards et il leur parlera de son
expérience à la ferme des croqu épines
un lieu de solidarité où le rendement à
tout prix a été
écarté